should these people go to jail for their
old tweets yes or yes
yes they should I don't even know who
these people are but they're
trillionaires Shane Dawson jeffree star
they've got their own literal planets
they own literal planets Geoffrey star
on Saturn and you're trying to cancel
him he owns the planet Saturn which date
date I don't know what they're doing
they're painting it with face paint
you've made an entire industry of people
that only talk about makeup what the
[ __ ] people in makeup used to not have
public personas because they didn't need
it who is that chick from Maybelline
nobody knew she was Rita Revlon whoever
the [ __ ] these Rita nobody cared
people knew Coco Chanel was that was it
but like it's cosmetics what is so
important about makeup
can someone illuminate this sick trend
for me please can someone help me
understand why people painting their
face like Harlequin clowns in their in
their room that is only lit by the blue
light of their computer and they sit
there and they put makeup on their face
and stare at reddit threads can someone
explain to me how this makes eight
trillion dollars a week they have more
money these people and you you can't
cancel them they own the earth they own
the earth on which you live your Twitter
doesn't matter I dig Shane dogs it's a
rate he owns the earth I don't know how
it happened I don't know how it happened
that the only thing that's about
profitable in this country anymore is
makeup that's the only industry we've
got left is people putting lipstick on I
I miss that somehow that trend missed me
but apparently one of them though the
Geoffrey star the one that looks like I
mean let's be very honest if you'd
bumped into Geoffrey star in real life
you would go what I mean your first
thought wouldn't be this is a beauty
consultant let's be very honest about it
is no shade to him or whatever I don't
even
anymore they're drenched it Oh Matt you
don't get a gender when you're a
trillionaire you don't get a gender
anymore you're a planet but if I bumped
in the Jeffrey star it would be like
interesting that they made their money
with cosmetics and no shade to them good
for him whatever good good god love you
I'm just confused as always I exist in a
permanent state of confusion on this
program I don't understand I look at
people out they all look like [ __ ] no
one's even wearing the makeup so I guess
people just wearing it in their [ __ ]
hovels they live it are they eating the
maker is it edible
no that's food nobody has any money or
food how are they swinging $100 makeup
cats who's buying this fat women in the
Rust Belt are sitting there put men
women whoever who's doing this
I thought everybody's money went to
opioids how do they have the money to
get going to make up now but you can't
cancel them they own you stop trying to
Ken I don't know why they're even
canceling them Shane Dawson did
blackface and one of the photos he looks
like Oprah weird he's a chubby gentleman
in Egypt blackface that's why I don't do
blackface I don't need people calling me
precious hashtag precious what's people
of a certain amount of money it's like
you what are you canceling does it
matter